the limbic system has primacy
over our brain it can hijack
neural activity instantly and that's why
when you smell smoke or somebody gets
too close
or if you hear a loud noise our limbic
system kicks in
it's one of those beautiful things that
has evolved with
us
my name is joe navarro and i am a
non-verbal communications expert
we are a species that is always
communicating but we're also
communicating with gestures
in fact we have been primarily
communicating
with gestures for millions of years
i think about 2.5 million years ago we
were all still in africa
we were surrounded by predators at all
times
lions tigers wild dogs
all these things were after us so we
evolved to communicate
silently but effectively we had to move
through the jungle we had to move
between
trees we had to move in all sorts of
environments very quietly
and still be able to communicate that
which mattered the most
which was what are my needs wants and
desires and what are my fears
if one of us saw a tiger or a lion
we evolved the capacity to freeze in
place
so that by freezing the predator would
move on and not
notice us this has been with us for
millions of years
all our earlier ancestors all our
hominids
had to adapt to this one behavior
which was to freeze and it allowed to
survive
another day those that ran initiated the
chase
trip bite sequence it was that
movement that was so perilous to our
species
and so we have behaviors that are
hardwired
in us it's part of our paleo circuits
these very ancient circuits that have
allowed us
to survive
deep within the brain is an area called
the limbic system and the limbic system
is both exquisite and elegant in that
it merely responds to the world it
doesn't have to really
think about the world the limbic system
is often
also referred to as the mammalian brain
and it can be activated in a variety of
ways
for instance if the room suddenly gets
too hot
your limbic system can be activated or
if it gets too cold
if you smell smoke the olympic system is
immediately activated it is on
while we sleep it is on while we think
we are in charge when we're writing
something
the limbic system is running in the
background it's like
software it's looking at it's listening
for
it's sensing are there things out there
that could hurt me
i'll give you an example if if you take
two
gas stations and they're identical
but you dim the lights of one
versus the other people will go to the
better
lit gas station without realizing why
they're doing it
and they're doing it because light
represents
visual clarity and you naturally feel
safer so even though they may charge you
a little bit more you'll still go there
because there's something about being
able to see
everything with greater clarity
those of you who have children probably
remember
whenever the baby was startled the baby
would
immediately bring up its hands and its
fingers would be
spread out this is called the moral
reflex
and this reflex we share with all
primates
which allows us to immediately grab onto
the hair
of those hairy individuals which we used
to be
and allows us to hang on this was
essential for survival remember even
before we were
australopithecines dependent on our
ability
to be able to hang on to hair so that a
very mobile and very agile mother could
move about
while we assisted in hanging on
the babinski reflex is very similar it
has to do with the
feet if you stroke the foot of a child
at a very young age
before they're two their toes
immediately spread out
again so they can grab onto hair and
hang on
or maybe you've never noticed for
instance when you lay a young baby down
as you put them on their back their hand
and arm goes into what's called the
fencing
posture and that is as they lay down
their head will turn to one side
and their arm will immediately come up
as though they're fencing
we think we go into the fencing posture
at this early age
to protect us from rolling over
if our arms were at our side then we
become a more perfect object
to roll
one of the other vestigial behaviors is
we have a reflex
that orients us it's referred to as the
orientation reflex and it's very ancient
in fact it's
most likely pre-reptilian it probably
goes back to our amphibian past
and that is that anytime there's any
movement
any any change in pattern we orient on
that
and so our eyes turn to it we react to
it
and then if it's coming at us we will
raise a hand to block it
fishermen will tell you that fish will
actually notice them they'll notice the
movement on the surface so they move
away fish are aware that they will be
hunted down by
birds and so their orientation reflex is
what usually saves them
but for humans we have never lost this
because this is key to survival we could
not have survived
as a species if we could not respond to
changes
in imagery or changes in pattern
you know often times when you're sitting
talking to somebody and somebody walks
by and your attention turns to them or
the screen
on a nearby television is on and then
all of a sudden there's a change in
color
or a change in pattern the orientation
reflex
makes us take notice and a lot of guys
use as
an excuse to look at the football game
when they should be paying attention to
their friends
but in fact it is anchored in our
biology and our physiology we
have passed this on to react to anything
that's different
because it goes directly to our survival
mode
[Music]
because the limbic system is responsible
for our survival
it can hijack neural activity
instantly and that's why you cannot
run to the edge of a building and just
look down
your brain says slow down inch
your way to the edge of that building
and then look down
one of the other things the limbic
system does is it
orients us away from anything that we
perceive
as hurtful or that we don't particularly
care for it says i will not permit you
to expose your ventral side
to that person which you perceive as
nasty or dangerous or whatever
and so we have a lot of collateral
behaviors
that are associated with a startling
situation for instance with primates
we know that when they're scared or
they're angry they open up their mouths
and they show their large canines well
we've lost our large
canines but in displaying our teeth
this was supposed to scare others
you'll see people react by tucking in
their thumbs
and this is very much part of what we do
in our species
which is when we're scared we tend to
bring our fingers together
and tuck our thumbs in it's not just
when somebody frightens us
you can see it sometimes at the poker
table you'll have poker players that
have a
lousy hand and you'll see their fingers
come together and their thumbs disappear
indicating just how weak they are
[Music]
we're not sure why we tend to tuck our
thumbs in
it may be in part something that we
evolved as we move
through areas where there's a lot of
vegetation so that
our opposable thumbs don't catch on
different objects i remember
an fbi agent friend of mine during an
operation
we were taking down some drug dealers
and we were jumping from one
house to the other over a fence and his
thumb
caught and just it was just completely
ripped off so it's not far-fetched that
this is a behavior
that we use so that we don't have any
appendages
sort of loose that could get caught and
the other one
that we most often see
is bringing a hand to the neck and
bring this little area here called the
suprasternal notch and if you
look at the photographs that are out
there of
predators this area of the body
is primarily where they go to suffocate
their
their prey and so our paleo circuits
when we're struggling with something or
we hear even something that's terrible
we instinctively develop this set of
procedures where we
cover the neck cover the mouth or tuck
the chin
in in an effort to protect ourselves
most of our behaviors that are universal
come from the limbic system and so
when i see a limbic response in
madison wisconsin of somebody touching
their neck i will also
see in botswana there's no difference
because they're universal they're also
very reliable
and so we can use it to assess others to
determine
what are they thinking what are they
feeling
or what might they be fearing